(soft tense music)
- [Reporter] In February,
Congress, grilled executives
from Robinhood and Citadel Securities
over their role in the
GameStop trading frenzy.
And throughout the hearing,
a phrase came up over and over again.
- Payment for order flow.
- With respect to payment for order flow,
we simply play by the rules of the road.
- [Reporter] Payment for order flow
is a decade-old practice
that's at the heart
of how commission-free brokers operate,
and it's creating controversy.
Critics claim that the practice creates
a conflict of interest
that is bad for investors.
- While it may enable free
commissions and explicit costs,
there are implied costs
we feel everyone ignores.
- [Reporter] But supporters say
the practice is misunderstood
and that it's actually good for investors.
- Whether you're a Robinhood
client or a Fidelity client,
you're getting a price
that is at or better
than the national best
bid or best offer, right?
That's the thing.
- Well, lemme ask-
- There's nothing nefarious going on here.
- [Reporter] Following
the GameStop episode,
the SEC is expected to conduct a review
that could change the rules
of payment for order flow
and how brokers operate.
(soft tense music)
When an investor buys a stock
on a commission-free trading app,
the transaction is
executed almost instantly.
But a lot is going on behind the scenes.
Let's take a look at the main players.
There are buyers,
the investors who want
to purchase a stock,
and there are sellers,
the investors who want to unload a stock.
There's also the broker,
the firm that accepts investors' orders
and make sure they get executed.
And finally, there are the market makers,
which buy the orders from
the broker and execute them.
These are usually high-frequency traders
like Virtu Financial
and Citadel Securities,
and they are the players
that make the trade actually happen.
- When you're the investor
and you're buying,
the market maker's selling.
If you're the investor and you're selling,
the market maker is buying.
But the market maker hopes
to do a lot of little trades
all day long and eventually
arrive at a place
where they're flat.
- [Reporter] Zero commission
brokers make money
by selling customers'
orders to market makers.
This is payment for order flow.
The practice enables trades to be executed
at a high volume very quickly.
It also means that most orders
entered by small investors
never get sent to public exchanges
like the New York Stock
Exchange or NASDAQ.
Instead, small investors'
orders get executed privately
by market makers.
Let's break down how the process works.
Say an investor wants to
sell 200 shares of a stock,
so they place an order with a broker.
The chances that another person
wants to buy that exact amount of shares
at the same time is pretty
low, but that's okay
because the broker routes
the orders to a market maker.
The market maker fills it
within a fraction of a second,
but that comes with risk,
the risk that the price
of the stock could fall
before the market maker
can sell the 200 shares
to someone else.
The market maker is paid
for taking on this risk
through what is known
as the bid-ask spread.
You can see it here.
The spread is the difference in price
between what buyers are paying for a stock
and what sellers are selling for it.
It doesn't usually amount to much.
On stock exchanges, it's
often just a penny per share.
When market makers
execute trades privately,
the spread can be even tighter.
This is because the prices can
be in fractions of a penny.
Say, using our example,
that the spread is just half a cent.
So buying and selling those 200 shares
would make the market maker $1.
But as millions of shares are traded,
the profits from the spread add up.
- It's easy money for them.
The retail investors are small,
they don't place very large orders,
and they don't tend to be
extremely well-informed
about the movements of the stock price.
- [Reporter] In 2020,
these brokerages collected
almost $2.6 billion in payments
for stock and option orders.
And this is part of what's
driving the current controversy
over the practice.
Some critics say that
payment for order flow
creates a conflict of interest
between the broker's duty
to seek the best execution for trades
and its desire to
maximize its own profits.
- In the US, brokers have
what is called a duty of best execution.
They have to get you the
best possible execution
on your trades, or at
least attempt to do so.
If a broker is taking a lot of money
in payment for order flow,
then odds are it's not really
giving you a best execution.
- [Reporter] Critics say this is because
brokerages could be tempted
to send customer orders
to the market centers that
pay them the biggest rebate
or that brokers could be
demanding greater payments
from the market makers.
This is why the practice is banned
in some other countries like the UK.
- In other countries
where payment for order flow is illegal,
everything has to go to exchanges
so everything is in the lit markets
where everybody can see
the prices coming together.
All the trading happens
kind of out in the open.
- [Reporter] Some critics
even worry that market makers
could be front-running
investor stock trades,
but supporters say these
claims aren't true.
Brokers and market makers argue
that payment for order
flow often gives investors
a better price than the best market price
and that it helps make trading easier.
- So payment for order
flow has a very big benefit
for investors, and that is,
it has allowed the emergence
of zero commission trading.
It was just a few years ago
that brokers were typically
charging 4.95, 7.95 or more
for a single stock trade.
A couple of years ago that went away
Robinhood set the practice,
and then a bunch of others
like Schwab, TD Ameritrade,
E-Trade following.
- [Reporter] In the past,
the SEC has approved
of payment for order flow
as long as brokers make
certain disclosures,
like where they're
routing investors' orders
and how much they're
getting paid for them.
The agency has said that small investors
generally get better prices
when their orders are sent
to market makers rather than exchanges.
But the volatility in GameStop
is raising alarms in Congress
where lawmakers are
calling for fresh scrutiny
of payment for order flow.
In February, SEC Acting
Chairwoman Allison Heron Lee
wrote a letter showing
support for a wholesale review
of the practice.
- If the review uncovers
any sort of abuses,
what I think is most
likely going to happen
is that the SEC will require
some sort of new disclosures
coming out of brokers and
maybe out of market makers.
If payment for order flow were banned,
market makers would still
be able to make money.
After all, they're still
doing the same thing,
collecting the bid-ask spread.
However, the thing that
would likely change
is that zero commission
trading would be endangered.
- [Reporter] As the GameStop
saga continues to unfold,
the future of payment for order flow
and zero commission
trading remains uncertain.
(soft tense music)